good evening members and offices of the
council and members of the press and
public I welcome you to this meeting of
the council I would like to take this
opportunity to invite alternate district
councillors and the officers for a
Christmas drink and mince pies in the
business suite after this meeting I very
very much hope that you will be able to
attend fire evacuation procedure if the
fire alarm is activated please vacate
the offices via the stairs either
through the security doors to my right
or opposite the lifts in the foyer
please do not use the lifts please
assemble in holy square on the on the
green offices will assist you and advise
when it is deemed safe to return to the
chambers webcasting of proceedings the
proceeding of this meeting will be
recorded and subsequently broadcast on
the Internet
I would advise that if filming takes
place anyone in attendance in the public
areas may have their image captured
I urge anyone filming proceedings to
avoid filming members of the public
particularly if there are children
present
does anyone intend filming the meeting
right ok any member of the public who
objects to the possibility of being
filmed may wish to take this opportunity
to leave the meeting any filming or
recording will not be permitted for any
item of business where exempt or
confidential information is considered
following the exclusion of the press and
public from the meeting would everyone
present please ensure that their mobile
phones are turned to silent and that
they are not used to make or receive
phone calls in the chamber whilst this
meeting is in progress
agenda item 1 apologies for absence
apologies were is safe from councillors
Connor Constantine in Gregory and Glen
Coleman cook are there any other
apologies
councillor Dexter
ah agenda item two minutes of the
previous meeting held on the 12th of
October 2017 I move that the minutes of
the meeting of the council held on the
12th October 2017 be approved and signed
as a correct record would the vice
chairman please second seconded madam
chairman do members agree thank you
gender item 3 a reminder to members I
felt that there was instances during the
last meeting of council when some
members appeared to be having their own
meeting while I X well I accept that
maybe it may be necessary at times to
pass a word between colleagues please
can I remind members to demonstrate
courtesy to other members by listening
when they address the council the
passing of councillor Gregory as members
will already be aware councilor Calgary
has recently passed away he was
initially elected as a Dane Park ward
councillor in 1995 and remained a
district councillor for over 22 years in
addition to his district councillor
duties councillor Gregory was also a
parish counselor for Moncton Parish
Council and Kane town an account county
councillor representing the Burton law
rural area I am sure council will join
me in expressing sympathy to councillor
progress family could all members please
stand for a minute's silence as a mark
of respect for the late councillor
Gregory
thank you does any moon does any member
wish to say a few words House counselor
Beaufort yeah thank you chairman I'm
sure we're all shocked and saddened by
the tragic and unexpected loss of King I
must say it still seems unreal to look
to my right and see that he's not there
he was a larger-than-life character with
a great sense of fun and humor talking
to fellow members since his death I was
struck by how many of them remarked on
the amount of time that Ken was prepared
to spend with them helping them on
council issues particularly in the era
of planning where his expertise was
legendary it was a powerful force in
local politics for over 20 years the
knowledge and commitment he brought to
Thanet council will be sorely missed
he will be very difficult now impossible
to replace Thank You councillor Beauford
would anybody else likes a few little
counsel Dawson thank you I just said
okay what's her bob baffert I said I
also wanted to let people know that on
the 18th of December there will be a
celebration to Ken's life at Christie's
wine bar in birch in turn so anyone that
wants to come along you're welcome
whichever party you know you're from it
didn't matter
okay thank you thanks Thank You
councillor Dawson councillor girl Brown
yes I would like to echo those
sentiments Ken Gregory to me was a great
friend I've never met somebody as highly
motivated as in the council work his
farm Kent Natalie Kent County Council he
was an outstanding guy and councillor
Bob Grove and I used to spend many a
time in the pub with him and he was a
life and so as it comes to the bay that
said but he will be sorely missed
councillor growth yeah I think it's yeah
yeah as council Crowe Brown said we did
spend many a time in our local East
hostelry he certainly was a man that
knew his aisles and he was certainly a
man as counts to pay for said new who's
planning and when he found out that I
was becoming chairman of planning he
couldn't have been fairer wiser more
helpful than any council I've ever known
he was certainly a good teacher to me
and he'll be sorely missed thank you
thank you all for those kind comments
right agenda item for
declarations of interest are there any
declarations of interest
gender item five petitions one petition
has been received and two petitions
returned to Council in accordance with
council procedure rule number 12 please
note that the council's Constitution
permits up to 30 minutes for the
consideration of petitions agenda item 5
a petition regarding Western under
clique facilities a paper petition
containing 1910 valid signatures and an
e petition containing 135 valid
signatures has been received by the
council I am pleased to welcome miss
Morgan to the meeting could you please
make your way to the top table
oh sorry mrs. Morgan you have five
minutes to sleep okay
we're gonna talk about the history of
the toilets so we've always had public
toilets in this area but somewhere along
the line the cafe took on the
responsibility of these toilets one
sudden water took out the cafe the
toilets disappeared too we suffered lots
of disruption with the recreational
grounds on the wall and Esplanade over
the last couple of years but to suffer a
long-term disruption of the toilets
seems a lot to bear we don't feel that
this is fair for the community to miss
out on such an important facility I'm
very nervous who would use these toilets
the local community will benefit
immensely from giving them reassurance
that they can walk drive cycle jog down
to the beach and use the conveniences if
necessary our Beach is a really well
used beach all year round and by dog
walkers fishermen a number of sports
groups local schools families beach
goers both local and day-trippers having
public toilets will make their visit far
more pleasant and longer as there's
nothing worse than having to cut your
journey short because of lack of
facilities equality and inclusion as it
stands at the moment the setup at the
Western and the cliff excludes those
that are elderly or disabled and for
families with small children our Beach
has a gentle sloping bay with golden
sands it's especially ideal for families
who wish to use this Beach with their
young children but this lack of
facilities is a hindrance we feel that
the convenience of the parking so near
the sea was the Western and cliff is
ideal for families and the elderly as
they don't have to walk too far to get
to the beach but they're put off by not
having their toilet facilities they're
disabled beach goers and day-trippers
are completely deterred from visiting
this area as there simply isn't the
facilities to support them we store in
hiding down our beach at present some
beach goers and members of the public
have been caught short so they've been
forced to urinate or worse down at the
beach this is unhygenic for the members
of the public and so
unacceptable and news toilet is over six
point not six miles away it's not that
far no point six miles away sorry
it does seem at times it does so I think
itself at the top at the West Cliff
behind the lookout cafe it's not
accessible for those with mobility
issues due to the amount of steps
between the beach and the toilets and
even for those without mobility issues
including myself the logistics of having
to pack up all your belongings and your
children and hike up to the top of the
cliff puts people off and visiting
promotion of the beach I know it's not
something it's not our main sans but we
still need to promote it because it is a
local beach so having these toilet
facilities at the Western and a cliff
would increase increase visitors to the
area on TripAdvisor the only thing that
comes up as a negative is the lack of
toilets so it's important for the whole
town it's not just for the area it's
important for the whole town that a
TripAdvisor is always on a positive and
the last thing is water for first aid
situation due to not having a lifeguard
in this Beach anymore because when off
to stone Bay because they've got beach
huts and visitors need to administer
first aid to injuries just having some
fresh water to clean out cups and simple
things like that
so therefore I'd like to present its
petition to you today to show you the
depth of the feeling amongst the local
community donations are nearly done it
that's it thank you
as the petitioner relates to an
executive function it will be referred
to cabinet without debate in accordance
with the council's petition scheme
agenda item 5b clean up a cleanup
Clifton will West petition this item is
to report back to the council's response
to the petition in accordance with the
council's petition scheme would members
please note the report agenda item 5c
Ramsgate sprint revival petition this
item is to report back the council's
response to the petition in accordance
with the council's petition scheme would
members please note the report Thank You
agenda item 6 questions from the press
on public
no questions have been received from the
press all members of the public in
accordance with council procedural
number 13 agenda item 7 questions from
members of the council three questions
have been received from members however
question three agenda item 7c regarding
council tax debt has been withdrawn from
the agenda at the request of the
councillor who submitted it agenda item
7a question number one from a member
regarding council tax
I call upon councilor matter face Thank
You chair my question is to Council at
onand can the cabinet member explained
the circumstances under which letters
were sent to those claiming single
person discount on their council tax
where some who had lost a relative who
had never lived at that address
were told to prove they lived alone I
call upon council Townend
to respond
thank you as part of the review process
to cross-reference various sources of
information such as the electoral roll
registers consumer and financial sector
information we used a credit reference
agency call credit in some circumstances
customers who had power of attorney for
family members were written to the
information received from call credit
was cross-reference with our records
before sending letters to ensure that we
did not send any communication out where
family members had passed away in cases
where the family member passed away out
of the area this would not have been
held on our records and in those cases
which were very few a letter was sent to
confirm no discounts were removed prior
to providing customers with the
appropriate advice opportunity to advise
of their current circumstances the
claiming of single-person discount
represents a very signal significant
reduction in the amount of customers
required to pay and hence a significant
reduction in the amount of income for
the counsel we want to ensure that every
single occupier pays the correct amounts
of council tax but there are a
significant number of customers who may
forget to tell us about a change in
their circumstances which results in
under payments all reasonable available
tools are used to try and identify these
cases to minimize income view data from
sources such as the credit reference
agency are used in good faith as there
are not enough resources to undertake
and an individual detailed review in
each case this review has highlighted
several cases where we have learned
lessons every customer that contacted
eks has been given full feedback by a
phone call and charges have been
implemented to future planned reviews as
a result changes correction sorry
changes you're not going to be
charged the new implementation I would
also like to apologize to those
customers that were contacted and asked
insensitive questions based on flawed
information it's worth noting that the
review was I has identified significant
numbers of customers who were no longer
entitled to the discount and have now
been rebuild for the full amount
councillor Matt's face do you have a
supplementary question think a chair I
do and thank you for that full
explanation so as a third party company
was contracted to undertake this
investigation can you give us can give
me and everybody else here assurances
that no data protection laws were
breached when these people's bank
accounts were accessed I would certainly
hope that is correct and I'm sure it
must be
agenda item 7b question number 2 from a
member regarding 19 holy square Margate
I call upon councillor Johnson thank you
very much chairman this is a question to
councillor Piper Kaplan member for
housing housing officers recently gave a
very detailed and worrying report on
homelessness and increasing waiting
lists for social housing and Fallot
could the cabinet member for housing
please confirm what efforts he has been
able to make to bring 19 Horry Square
back into use for much-needed homes
thank you I call upon councillor Piper
to respond Thank You Gerry Johnson do
you have a supplementary question I
certainly do ward councillors and
particularly those of us in Margate
central regularly see members of the
public who are in dire need of housing
and it's an embarrassment for us to meet
them in the Gateway and look across the
park to number 19 wholly square which
continues to be empty
our administration put a new roof on it
and made it comfortable and dry but it
was stuck in this whole theme of the
connection with the Theatre Royal and
really goes back to the history of the
old London Tavern unfortunately I see no
movement unless the leader can tell us
otherwise oral counselor Piper on the
big announcement the leader made earlier
in the year that Soho were taking over
the Theatre Royal and of course that the
whole project would advance it was news
to us on the night it was news to the
public and it was news in fact to your
leisure who've now had an extension to
March for their arrangements with the
council so can we have the truth is Soho
taking over or are we left with still a
big empty building when we're paying an
outside company - how some of our most
desperate people
I call upon counselor Reverend Piper to
respond Thank You Jen I hope on this
occasion that counselor Johnson won't
mind me mentioning a time when she was
leader of this council the council's
cabinet considered the property at the
meeting she chaired on the 20th of
January 2015 and agreed to dispose of 19
holy square together with the Theatre
Royal it considered that linking the two
buildings would provide the best
opportunity to safeguard the future of
the theatre this arrangement creates a
commercial opportunity to generate an
income from 19 olly square which will
help fund the future of the theatre
the council has now completed a
marketing exercise for the disposal and
selected a preferred bidder which has
previously been announced as she
mentions by the leader in December 2016
council have now agreed heads of terms
subject to contract an application for
Heritage Lottery funding has been
submitted and a stage 1 decision is
expected soon we will be in a position
to announce the details early in the new
year and we're optimistic that this will
ensure a long and successful future for
this important local heritage asset
members may recall the recent addition
of an extra two million pounds the
council with that the council has now
committed a total of 30 million pounds
to the delivery of 150 new and
refurbished or formidable homes and we
are about halfway through completing
this ambitious program and the program
includes empty buildings that have been
returned to use in both Ramsgate and
Margate these new homes are desperately
needed to help prevent and address
homelessness and we continue to look for
opportunities to do more chair may I
also remind members that the Department
of Housing Department has been nominated
for two prestigious awards for the
excellent work that they have done and
will hear the results from the panel
also in the new year congratulations I
believe are due to them for their
sterling efforts in this case thank you
Jeff
come counselor Rayford yeah thank you to
your mum dif you indulge me just for a
minute
I'd like to ask through you if mr. house
could produce an idiot's guide as to
what isn't isn't acceptable in a
question to this council council
savaging myself put questions in for
this meeting tonight and they were both
rejected one on the basis it was
political and one on the basis what what
one I thought was okay because it
referred to a motion that had already
been agreed and passed an action agreed
so could you please just produce
something that's very simple and
straightforward so that we've got a
chance of getting them right in the
future thank you
Thank You counsel David yes well I
thought we had to explain to you why the
questions weren't acceptable but I'm
more than happy to I'm come back to you
after the meeting explain further weird
respect that isn't what I asked I asked
if you could produce some sort of guide
that gives us some guidance as to what
can and can't be any I'm sure it's in
the Constitution that you know maybe we
don't read it in the same way that you
did this yes some other maps apply
clarity from the Constitution agenda
item 7c also stated before this question
has been withdrawn agenda item 8 motions
on notice one motion unnotice had had
been received
however this motion has been withdrawn
from the agenda at the request of the
councillor who submitted it council mata
face will be considered it will be
considered at a future meeting of
Council in accordance with council
procedural three agenda item nine
leaders report I can't on the leader
Thank You chairman compared so many of
the meetings we have in our calendar
this one seems have a fairly light
agenda and perhaps that is appropriate
during this season of Advent Advent is a
season observed in the Christian
calendar as a time of expectant waiting
and preparation for the celebration of
the birth of Jesus began this year on
the Sunday the 3rd of December and
finishes on Sunday the 24th of December
Christmas Eve a day when I suspect many
of us are more likely to be reading
children and grandchildren Clement
Clarke Moore famous 1823 poem the night
before Christmas it's natural time for
reflection
perhaps healing after another difficult
year indeed there have not been many
easy years in local government since the
financial crisis of 2008 I would remind
members of the starkest slide in budget
briefings and discussions of the
differences between the financial year
2012-13 and that coming in 2021 in
2012-13 this council enjoyed a revenue
budget somewhere in the region of 21 and
a half million pounds of we tried 11
beginning
came to this counseling government of
block grants and new homes bonus while
the financial year 2021 our predicted
revenue budget will be around 16 and a
half million pounds all of which all of
which has to be raised locally because
all government support will have ended
at that time closing the budget gap
which has become a constant battle
although members are being briefed about
difficult choices interrupts our budget
meeting in February 2018 that work
continues over the holiday period indeed
we do not usually get confirmation of
government figures until the very
beginning of the holiday season and in
recent years that final set of figures
has always contained a couple of
unwarranted welcome unwelcome surprises
let's hope this year already difficult
enough will at least spare as that I
could at this point probably nominate
various decision makers in traditional
Christmas rolls the Grinch may be or
Scrooged may seem particularly
appropriate but in a very real sense
that is against the spirit of the Advent
season or even perhaps the previously
you are oddly entitled pagan festival of
Saturnalia which predates it both are
about hope and a vision of light during
the darkest nights of the winter perhaps
I can suggest the greatest light we have
as a council is to be found amongst our
hard-working staff who enjoy troublesome
financial a budgeted climate continue to
work hard to provide the very best
services they can in the best traditions
of public service on your behalf I want
to use the bonhomie of this time of year
to publicly thank them all and perhaps
we could express our thanks with a round
of applause which could metaphorically
at least be heard
stunning examples include the
Environmental Action team working in
Clintonville who in eight hectic weeks
recently collected the 32 additional
tons of waste including wood rubble soil
and bad ways litter picked 59th Street
shifted 19 abandoned or nuisance
vehicles put in new layer line marking
and enforcement in Gordon Road undertook
eighteen mixed bulky waste tip moves
move 35 mattresses 15 cities 12 old push
bikes and numerous fridges and in shine
to prevent its return issued in excess
of 800 warning letters via the private
sector housing licensing team not bad
for 8 weeks I think he would agree it's
on the back of such sterling efforts
that the independent chair of the
improvement board gave us a glowing
recommendation for the work undertaken
overcoming the influence peer review of
2014 that is particularly strongly
reflected in the nomination and success
of various parts of our Council for
awards we've already heard tonight about
the Housing and Finance Institute
prestigious national housing business
ready status Richard Hopkins was awarded
the Kent hasn't first of the year 2016
by the Kent Housing Group East Kent
Services one behavior change at the MJ
Achievement Awards 2017 visit pallets
have been prolific Award winners tourist
information first of the year in 1516
tourist information first of the year in
1516 silver and gold bronze award
tourism hospitals for the website in
1617 first in the southeast to fourth in
England for social media activity market
task force have simply been a perfect
ward winner winner of the dup game
changes award 1516 finalists in Kent
housing Excellence Awards 2016 run up
with the chief constables award for
community policing in 2017 and acute
service line winner again to meadow NHS
Social Care Partnership trust awards
2017 I also want to acknowledge all of
the hard work undertaken by councillors
as well particularly the casework often
hidden away from view but which can make
a real difference to residents lives and
on behalf of all of those residents I
would like to thank you for all of the
many hours over and above the call of
duty many of you I know
to do that casework and I suspect that
case where it is set to increase in the
new year we've all I think probably
heard something of the difficulties the
new Universal Credit System and even
this evening we've had some discussion
of and previous briefings on the growing
issue of homelessness these are common
problems for all local authorities but
clearly bite harder in areas of lower
income and deprivation
however again as we already heard pass
through and answers a question this
evening our hard-working housing team do
everything they can to alleviate the
problems and of course it's great to
know that they have been nominated a
shortlisted rather for not one but two
LDC Awards the announcer to which will
take place in March 2018 so to return to
where I began as politicians we were
recognized as tools for trade some of
the more well-known lines about
Christmas in the beginning was the word
is that famous Christmas reading from
Sanjana gospel and some other residents
may yet be thankful for a silent night
at least from us
it is it is perhaps a good moment
remember that our roots here in this
country come from judeo-christian
culture and our moral behavior is as
common with all the main religions of
the world
or should be it's a family time more
than any other part of the year and I
trust that you will all find that time
both restful and in joyful so in those
famous words not perhaps the ones
expected of bah humbug can I wish you
rather a merry Christmas to you all and
to all a good night
I call upon counselor Beaufort to
comment on or ask questions in relation
to the leaders report yeah Thank You
chairman yeah sort of changed a lot of
good stuff in there tonight leader and I
think that your comments on the
environmental action in Cliffton bill
are well merited is a really a superb
result but one of the things I'm really
glad about is that in the process we've
issued 800 warning notices we often
forget that it's people that create
litter and mess now councils get the
blame for the streets being messy but
it's people that do it
I think we need more penalties more
enforcement but I certainly also think
we need more education I'm also a little
bit concerned that some of the resources
that may be being poured into
Cliftonville means that other areas I'm
not getting the service that they need
I've had a number of complaints about
the state of the streets in Broadstairs
and one of the fat C's that the
seasoning Broadstairs are getting much
longer but we have a seasonal collection
of bin emptying schedule that changes
when it's themed to be winter that means
fewer bin collection bit fewer empty
ends and so on and the litter problem
has been really quite serious having
said that I do think that we ought to be
thinking as a council about things that
we can do to prevent this problem
because what strikes me as odd is that
you'll see somebody approach a being
clearly already full and they very
carefully and neatly put their rubbish
down by the side of it only for the wind
and seagulls to move it around and I'm
sure that if they only thought they
might find the next bin might be less
full or they might even take it home and
I noticed there's a sign on the fennec
way so I'm taking this at home many do
so I do really think that we also be
looking at things like that and perhaps
we need dialogue with some of the
outlets in our towns because an awful
lot of the rubbish that's around relates
to a sort of rubbish that comes from
take away food places and stuff like
that so I think we ought to be looking
at that I also endorse your price for
our staff the list of awards and
achievement really is impressive and it
does seem as though we punch well above
our weight in terms of excellence
I also echo your recognition of the hard
work of tDCS councillors they certainly
received plenty of brickbats and
certainly more brickbats than bouquets
and they certainly don't do it for the
money I think looking forward 2018 is
going to be an important and potentially
difficult year for TDC Council is
currently reorganizing and probably has
to keep on doing so not only to help
meet budget constraints but also to
deliver services in a much more inner
Tevere why we've heard the increased
pressures that
come on this council and so the jobs
going to get harder I think it's also
true that the headline event of the
coming year is the public inquiry into
the local play and we're all aware that
there's still a potential sticking point
here in the shape of Menston I would
urge you leader to consider all options
up to now you've spent a lot of time
talking about the problems if we don't
approve the plan in its current form and
frightening this with the potential
housing numbers but there are
alternatives and I think we should be
looking at them they're certainly
precedence for having a twin-track
approach which would allow for two
potential outcomes for the most in sight
what's the rest of the plan could be
agreed this would have the dual benefit
of allowing the progress of the plan to
stay on target and also removed the need
to completely rewrite the plan in the
event of a DCO of being granted you'll
had lots of references to the Bible in
your speech I come from a different
place so when I looked up things to talk
about
regards Christmas I came up with the
quote from Bart Simpson and and here is
people to remember the true meaning of
Christmas the birth of center and
Bernhard Menon who said that a Christmas
he used to give his kids packs of
batteries with a note saying toys not
included chairman members members of the
public residents the fanuc have a Merry
Christmas and a peaceful and happy new
year
thank you I call upon the leader to
respond
I I call upon counselor Matt's face to
comment on or ask questions in relation
to the leaders report thank you could I
ask did you really say DUP or did you
actually in DWP in your speech and I
would just thank you for your good
wishes and obviously we share those but
could I remind you at the last full
council meeting you told me where there
was no truth and what I said about ane
at Kubik um being under threat I also
have to ask at this point when will the
cabinet advisory group on qqm meet again
because I can't even remember the last
time we met we've only met twice but in
the light of the publicity currently
being given to the various options
relating to our NHS our NHS in East Kent
surely we need a stronger position that
is for the benefit of our residents who
are most likely to have difficulty to
get to Canterbury or Ashford in light of
the apparent ignoring now of the so
called golden hour however a little bit
of optimism has come in today Paul
Carter at KCC apparently during the
debate and answered to a question from
councillor Constantine who had was
allowed to put a question through
somebody else because she's ill in bed
Paul Carter said he favoured a third
option not option 1 or option 2 so from
our point of view I think any
alternative option to just the one into
that we're on the table can only be a
good addition to the debate ok
I call upon the leader to respond well
of course that entirely depends what the
third option is in the Council of
Governors informal meetings that
followed the meeting at County Hall I
did suggest that option three was
missing because option three would seem
to me to be possibly look at where the
housing that you might get his most
valuable I suspect that might be
Canterbury and invest that money in the
other two we'll see I call upon Council
Grove to comment on or ask questions in
relation to the leaders report thank you
yes listening to both sides there
councillor Beaufort in councilor worlds
there very interesting some of the
things I do agree with counsel paper
especially on the litter side we have a
big problem with that in the countryside
as you well know but as far as the
report is concerned and I'm concerned I
think it was like a Christmas card and
councillor Wells opened it was full of
happiness and glitter wasn't it and I
think that's the way these councils
should go and let's hope next year that
we can have a good cross party working
party and really get that it on the on
the right route and going I wish you
take this opportunity to wish you and
the officers and the public America I
suppose think it call upon the leaders
to respond nope Genda item 10 report to
the chairman of the overview and
scrutiny palan panel
I call upon councillor David Saunders to
present his report thank you chairman
members the report before you this
evening outlines both the overview and
scrutiny panel and subgroup meeting
since we last met inset in October as
you will see the corporate performance
review working party met on the 13th of
November and I would confirm that the
Community Safety Partnership working
party is scheduled to meet on the 20th
of February 2018 next year believe it or
not doesn't time fly
in addition and as I previously advised
three draft plan working group meetings
were held in advance of the scrutiny
meeting which was held on the twenty
November at which panel members tabled a
number of points of concern for
consideration members in view of a
number of inquiries and comments I've
received in respect of the subsequent
scrutiny meeting I feel obliged to
elaborate on the report within the
papers before you this evening
the report ends with what is
constitutionally correct by saying there
were no recommendations submitted to
cabinet in the period under review but I
would particularly like to elaborate on
the outcome of the meeting on the 21st
November for those who weren't there on
page 31 of the report that the scrutiny
panel had before them on the evening
three alternative options were outlined
for consideration with option 1 being
recommended for adoption although panel
members raised points of concern at the
scrutiny meeting no formal proposals or
amendments were tabled from the floor
and therefore the chairman was duly
bound to propose the recommendation
which was seconded and the as the
published minutes will show and they are
now on the public availability when put
to the vote panel members declined to
endorse the recommendation on a margin
of 9 to 1 I trust that this now
satisfactorily explains the current
position and members I would thank you
for your patience thank you
Thank You councillor Saunders
agenda item 11 flexible use of capital
receipts updated strategy strategy 2017
to 18 I would advise that in accordance
with council procedure rules 17.6 I will
call for a recorded vote on the motion
or any amendments and substantive
motions
I call upon councilor town in thanks
Jeff this report sets out a proposal to
apply to the Department for Communities
and Local Government to use some capital
receipts for the purposes of funding
transyl native projects this proposal
requires the approval of council and DC
LG because of a requirement under
government regulations issued in 2016
the two specific projects named in 2017
18 are the corporate restructuring and
digital transformation both of which one
have one-off costs to be funded from
receipts but which have ongoing annual
savings this will help enable the
council to deliver its medium-term
financial strategy I move the
recommendation is there a second
it counts to Beauford
I instruct the monitoring office ii to
conduct the recorded vote yeah
councillor Fenner sorry I was just
wondering if I was going to be a debate
you can speak if if you feel you need to
yes indeed ah I have some concerns about
this use of asset disposal for me it
should be useful capital projects such
as buying and doing help empty
properties to try and ease the
homelessness crisis instead of at
central government is forcing local
councils to sell the assets to
counteract the consequences of a
reduction in government funding in the
name of austerity this Dogma is hurting
the delivery of public services and what
is perverse about it is the fact that in
spite of years of austerity the national
debt is going up to 90 percent of GDP
why because austerity is damaging the
social fabric and it is causing even
more problems than it is supposed to
solve at our local level we are in a
situation where we have to restructure
to create efficiency savings by cutting
out totally some services but this will
inevitably cause problems elsewhere
which at some point will have to be
addressed and funded regrettably
I think that this council is caught in a
downward spiral which is not of its own
doing but
of central governments I have some
questions about this what happens if the
assets do not sell or if they do not
provide the necessary amounts that are
needed for the extra funding and what
will this process do is it not going to
set up a dangerous precedent to have
this flexible use of acid disposal again
in in future years I do think that it is
important for this council to address
response thank you
councillor townand would you like to
respond yes as far as the assets we're
talking about those have already been
sold
it's birthing and I'm told that we can't
do not need to apply to a political
speech
counselor else would you like - yeah I
mean only to say very simply a straight
forwardly clinic speech lovely points
great - their sympathy many ways sadly
by law we have to produce a balanced
budget and and as part of that as I
outlined in the leaders report earlier
in the Nam jolly bit you know we are
looking at a massive reduction in
revenue for this council at the same
time as people expecting the services to
improve and improve and improve and at
some stage we have to take steps that
are difficult and uncomfortable in order
to actually make that budget balanced
that is the law that is what we have to
do the monitoring officer to conduct the
recorded roads Thank You chairman
councillor Ashby that's a Bainbridge
that's AB a furred Castle Braidwood Casa
brim
Casa Buckley Casa Campbell councillor
Keith Coleman cook councillor crow brown
classic Curran Casper Dawson Casper de
casa della Casa Dennis councillor Dixon
counselor Edwards councillor Evans
councillor Jeremy Fairbrass castle in
forever us casa Falcon councillor Fenner
Catholic game Catholic Grove
Casa hillman Casa house gasses Jay Jones
cathode Johnston casa Larkins kazna
Martin Casa matter face counselor
Parsons counselor Partington counselor
Casa de Linda Piper counsel Reverend
Stewart Piper Casa Linda pots cats Laroy
pots counselor Roger's house there is a
key councillor David Saunders counselor
Maeve Saunders counselor Savage
katha shank catalyst Thomas merch Singh
counselor Taylor counselor Taylor Smith
Casa de Tomlinson counselor Townend
counselor Venables castles
that is pastern
agenda item 12 2018 to 19 fees and
charges well remember please refer to
the supplementary agenda number one I
would advise that in accordance with
council procedure rules seventeen point
six I will call for a recorded vote on
the motion or any amendments and
substantive motions
I call upon councillor Townend peg to
share this report sets out the
recommendations of cabinet on the 30th
of November following overview and
scrutiny panel on the 21st of November
cabinet decided to recommend the council
the cancellation of the increases for
bulky waste
we also recommend it the removal of the
cremation charges for unviable babies
going beyond the overview and scrutiny
recommendation cabinet also proposes the
removal of the charge for stillborn
babies and those under one month old
this estimated loss of income resulting
from the removal of these charges to be
is insignificant in the context of the
overall income generated from the
proposed increases I would like to draw
members attention to a typographical
error that has been brought to my
attention in the supplementary agenda
page 816 the heading disposal of trim a
created remains should obviously read
disposal of cremated remains Albion Road
car park of searching ttan has for the
past two years been subsidized by
Bertrand Paris Council to enable the
first 30 minutes of parking to be pegged
at 20 P this proposed future the
proposed full charge from April is one
pound for hour
the council has had constructive
discussions with Bertrand and parish
council regarding their subsidy on this
arrangement and whether or not they wish
to continue with it we have reached a
two-year agreement for the subsidy to
continue at 2005
100 pounds for 2018-19 and 3000 pounds
for 2019-20 the royal harbor carpark
Ramsgate has for the past two years been
subsidized by Ramsgate town council to
enable free Saturday parking this
arrangement was an alternative to the
council's original intention which was
to make Canon Road the Ramsgate car pod
that offered free Saturday parking
Ramsgate Town Council has today engaged
with Council to discuss their updated
subsidy therefore I propose that the
Saturday charge in respect of the royal
harbor and cannon Road car parks are not
approved by council tonight approval of
these charges can be considered by
cabinet in January for final council
approval in February they therefore
prepares to Council that there is an
amendment the romantic recommendation to
be it is recommended that council
consider and approve the fees and
charges as listed in annex 1 with the
exception of the parking charges in
respect to the royal harbor and cannon
Road car parks Ramsgate is there a
second
anyone wish to debate I instruct the
monitoring officer to conduct
Oh
counsel matter face sorry that's all
right I just wanted to highlight the
costs of replacement bins I know in the
scheme of things it's a small part of
these fees and charges but in many cases
the damage to an existing black bean red
bag food caddy etc is not necessarily
down to the householder my red bag bag
went AWOL had my address on it it just
disappeared I would have certainly been
a little bit agreed having to pay eight
pounds to get a replacement are these as
there any scope with these charges that
somebody who maybe has moved into a
property and the bin has gone with the
previous owner and any kind of leeway in
that but also if you're brown food caddy
has been damaged by the bin men hurling
it down the driveway as I have actually
seen since grossly unfair that the
household has to pay for the placement
or the wheelie bin that got left so
close to the curb edge that a lorry
coming along drove straight over it I've
also seen that it just strikes me as
being slightly unfair to charge some of
the people and who are among the poorest
in our in our community these what I
consider quite excessive charges so I
would just like to ask if there's any
leeway in that particular part of these
fees and charges thank you
I call upon counts returning we
excuse me we haven't actually increased
those charges they remain the same
councillor Johnson thank you very much
chairman and we'd be failing in our duty
if we didn't to come here and report
back to you what members of the public
say to us
whether it's on parking whether it's on
replacement bins or as kind of store
matter face has now said about the red
bags the red bags we weren't being
charged for them but it looks as if we
will now be charged for them and so the
the particular issue that sorry it's a
particular particular issue that's been
raised by residents with me if you buy a
property and we're very lucky that so
many people wish to buy properties here
they move into the new property and they
find they haven't got the bin the
previous owners either taken the bin or
it's been damaged it's disappeared and
I've had to ask officers if we could
have been replacements for people and
the answer is they can have one if they
pay for them it's after etc some of the
bins have actually been damaged by I'm
afraid staff working for us and people
have told me this so that's one issue
the other one is about the car parking
charges and I know the reasons why we
have to increase at cetera et cetera but
we have a particular complaint coming
for residents in the ward
where people need to park in dreamland
because they can't park on the roads
they're just absolutely packed already
people are asking for permits and I've
had no answers to emails now for nearly
a month on questions to do with permits
but the Dream Land Charges at twelve
pounds for the five hours plus is a lot
more expensive than the 750 that you'll
pay when you go into the Arlington car
park so we're shooting ourselves in the
foot people will go to the cheapest one
first particularly I'm getting
complaints for people who are service
providers as in hairdresser along each
and road constantly contacts me and
officers to say it's a very expensive
haircut from his customers we really
need to look at the whole picture
and the impact we're actually having and
I would really appreciate replies to my
emails from officers when I'm
representing my constituents thank you
I instruct their monitoring officer to
conduct the recorded roads
Thank You chairman councillor Ashby as a
Bainbridge
kasib Hayford has a brain would that's a
brim causa Buckley Casa Campbell Casa
Keith Coleman cook
Kazik row Brown that saccharine
councillor Dawson casa la de casa della
Casa Denis councillor Dixon councillor
Edwards councillor Evans councillor
Jeremy Fairbrass castle in Fairbrass
casa Falcon councillor Fenner Castle a
game Catholic Grove councillor Hillman
Casa house councillor Jay Jones Casa
Johnston casa Larkins caster Martin Katz
the matter face Kelsey Parsons Casa
Partington Casa Linda Piper
that's the Reverend Stewart Piper Casa
Linda pots councillor Roy pots
councillor Rogers counselor is ecchi
councillor David Saunders councillor
Maeve Saunders councillor savage
Catholic ankh customers purchasing
counselor Taylor
Castle Taylor Smith councillor Tomlinson
counter Townend
causa Venables castle wells that's
agreed thank you
agenda item 13 representation on outside
bodies would members please refer to
supplementary agenda number one I call
upon councillor Wells thank you
we have as yet had spots of
conversations where the group leaders
found anybody who is willing to
volunteer for the two vacancies we
pursue coconut
and they are about action for rural
communities and about parking
representation I think that's a fair
description council wife and I will
continue to ask volunteers but if
anybody has a stunning wish to be
involved in those particular activities
would they please let us know thank you
agenda item 14 changes to committees
panels on boards 2017-18 would members
please refer to supplementary agenda at
number one proportion proportion
allottee as described within the report
consensus on the options has been
achieved between group leaders so unless
any member wishes to propose an
alternative option I propose option 1 as
shown in the supplementary agenda
would the vice chairman please second
seconded madam chairman do members agree
thank you nomination of members to serve
on committees drug leaders may wish to
take this opportunity to advise of any
change to their nominations to
committees panels and board for the
remainder of 2017-18 I call upon
councilor Beauford yeah thank you chair
like to take councillor Taylor Smith off
of governance and all dydt and
councillor Savage off of Licensing and
additionally counts the bambridge off of
planning and put councillor Taylor Smith
under planning thank you
does any other broadly they wish to make
any amendments to their committee
nominations thank you agenda item 15
dreamland and cinema mod rates funding
of Disability Discrimination Act
compliantly the purpose of this item is
only to inform counsel that this
individual cabinet member decision was
treated as urgent in accordance with
paragraph 4 of the budget and policy
framework procedurals
and was exempt from calling in
accordance with the overview and
scrutiny procedure procedurals whilst
members can debate the decision-making
making process the substantive decision
cannot be debated would members please
note the report thank you that concludes
the business for this meeting of Council